holiday music is in full swing now and
something to add into your rotation is
Jonathan Grant's new holiday album It's
called Christmas wish Jonathan joins us
today to tell us all about it Jonathan
congratulations on the album thank you
so much you're looking quite festive
today we're in the holiday spirit look
at you you look very festive well we're
ready to talk about all things holiday I
love holiday music tell us a little bit
about the album well you know it yeah
holiday music is so nostalgic for all of
us so when putting the album together I
really focused on you know picking my
favorites from the past and and some
some more contemporary ones but then
really focusing on on coming up with
Arrangements that were unique to me and
and how did I want to take this and say
this is mine and this is how I want to
project it to the to the universe you
know well how special is that and
something else special is you have some
some guest performers throughout the
album who who is lucky enough to be on
the album with you well the inspiration
for the album actually I mean a lot of
people through the years have been
saying Jonathan do a Christmas album but
last Christmas I was talking with my
dear friend Grammy winner jazz legend
Diane sure on the phone and we were
talking a lot through the holidays and
Grown-Up Christmas List came on one of
my playlists which is a Dave Foster song
and I sent it to her and then we started
talking and and we decided to record it
as a duet and then I thought well if
we're gonna have this single we might as
well have an album to go with it so
that's how the whole project kind of got
launched and the song with her is
absolutely beautiful it's from an
adult's perspective that's asking Santa
not for toys but for world peace I love
that and it's so beautiful that one song
kind of led to the entire album for you
and it's available now right where can
people find it it's on all music
platforms so Spotify Apple music Pandora
anywhere you find music perfect in time
for the holidays you're doing a special
kickoff at the Smith Center just how
great does it feel to have it out in the
universe oh you know I've I've been
seeing singing Christmas music all
spring and summer so it's really great
to finally get it lunched out and it's
really kind of a special thing because
so many people make memories through the
holidays of course so it's really
special to think that maybe
um my music is kind of in the background
while they are making their new memories
yes you're part of all of our holiday
memories this year congratulations
Jonathan I'm so excited to listen to the
whole album and I just can't wait to
hear it and I love my grown-up Christmas
list thank you so much for being here
thank you my pleasure